I was going to say um for you like
you've always been somebody like how do
you deal
with um the negatives of being in the
public eye and being in a relationship
because I feel like I you've you've
that's got to be like a hard thing to
kind of like cuz you want to keep your
private life private as much as you can
but you're also you you know what I'm
saying I'm also an artist and I got a
sing about what how I feel and things
like that um honestly I just tell what I
want to tell and whatever comes
out it comes out because it I don't know
like it just it it happens you can't but
even in that you don't respond like you
just you just deal with it in in your
household but um I mean how do I deal
with it I just like oh I just answered
it I just tell what I want to tell yeah
for sure um has there been someone who
you've met so far cuz I always say in
the music industry there's tons of like
uh people you know people you work with
uh Associates but not necessarily
friendss uhuh has there been any artists
who you've bonded some real friendships
with since you've uh been doing the
music thing well well how would you what
would you call a friend and what would
you call an associate well associatees
like yo we work together we hang we we a
did the video like you really ain't
seeing somebody or talking to them
outside of like the work like you know
but if there's somebody who you could
you know always call on for relationship
advice or or music advice or someone you
just chat with or like an actual friend
you know the the difference between a
work associate and a friend I don't have
an actual industry friend I don't but I
do have Associates like people that
would check on me from time to time um
you know and outside of music and stuff
and I appreciate it because I mean
sometimes you you can't be friends with
people um you cuz y'all don't have
enough time like I live in Atlanta most
of my peers live in LA so like we not
seeing each other on a daily basis or
but I do have those people that would
check on me I don't really have I can't
say I have friends so like that I'm like
this way yeah they're like yo let's go
let's go get lunch just cuz cuz it's
Tuesday no more I have like more of a
actually yeah I barely have friends so
like in life you have a no you have a
tight Circle very tight Circle as you
should yeah yeah no that's fair uh on
the EP you got LM Eric Bellinger young
boys on here um sh shout out to uh uh L
who's also so amazing talent amazing
she's amazing talent she's one of the
ones that check on me she's super super
sweetheart yeah yeah have uh what's uh
what is that a studio session situation
or is that you send this the record off
to her type I send it to her because
once again I was in Atlanta and she's in
La so but we did tour together um for
the Mary J BL tour we both got to open
up I was there actually I went in New in
Brooklyn did you see did you see did you
see me in the red in the red fur I was I
was I I think I caught the tail end of
your thing me and Doc wner were across
the street having dinner and then we
came and you were on yeah oh that yeah
cuz yeah I forgot yeah that was a crazy
show the Brooklyn show at barlay yeah
that man she brought brought everybody
out bro New York's energy be crazy like
I love New York yo that's crazy in there
rocking yeah no that was a w again Mary
J had like fabulous and Puff Daddy and
uh jiss and I feel like Fat Joe I don't
know it was like all in New York a lot
of people mhm what has uh did like you
and Mary develop any sort of like she
give you some game all you guys want yes
she definitely gave me some game she
gave me some game for sure um I'm of
course every every OG is going to tell
you to like keep going no matter what
but she definitely told me
like she told me to take my time and
like wait with
marriage um she been through it yeah
she's been through it public I mean I've
been through it too though I was already
married before she told me that so um
but I am I feel like this time around I
am we have been taking our time I mean
we've been together for almost 6 years
now and people complain cuz you know I
always I always joke around like where
my ring G you know but um in reality I'm
just like whenever he I rather a man be
like
ready like he better hurry up yeah no he
better hurry up but I'm saying though
like he better hurry up no but I'm
saying
that things should be handled before I
feel like um marital counseling is
really good like premarital counseling
before
yeah because like a lot of times I do
see like couples last a long time
outside of marriage and soon as they get
married it [__] things up they get
divorce and I'm a heavy believer in
marriage I still believe in marriage I
still believe it could work is it all
depends on the two people and of course
keeping God like in your marriage you
know what I'm saying
but um yeah it ain't it ain't no
rush but it's not a rush for marriage
but it is like a little rush for like
the Ring The Ring cuz it's like okay at
least if you propose then we know where
we headed we've had conversations about
it like I know that he's going to but
it's like okay six years yeah but you
know sometimes men they want to get
certain things out the way like he wants
to put his clothing line and you know
like they want to
feel like they got a portion of their
life if you guys get married you Mak him
sign the
prup um is it going to be the prenup H
we haven't we spoke about that haven't
signed that thing we spoke about it um I
don't know though I don't I don't know
but probably yeah for sure I just feel
like that it's only fair that if we walk
away from each other it's only fair that
we walk away with what we came with you
know what I'm saying I agree 100% yeah
but I feel like I got the kind of
relationship too that like I don't think
he would ever try to you don't think no
I don't think so I hey you don't think I
don't think so I don't think he'll try
to come for my money get the preep
that's all I say I feel you like it's
smart it is very smart but I'm just
saying the person that I know no I I get
it you know what I'm saying
I get it but um run that prenut bro a
lot of women don't think though and they
do end up you know but yo were you did
you ever when you were on tour with Mary
J BL did you ever see like how I always
am curious like when these like like she
wore like 11 outfits mhm how does that
work is there is there like a breakaway
pants on all these dresses and [__] like
the way n players have every tour I've
done like I just worn like one outfit I
mean well no I on my birthday I feel
like I had a show where I changed once
oh my God you go behind stage and you
just like everybody is there like six
people just ripping [__] off of you yes
wow yeah I just saw I just saw scor yeah
sior ciss had like 11 outfits and I was
just like it was so fast the way that's
amazing that's amazing but like um do
cat had one outfit I I probably would
end up end up sticking with one outfit
or two if I have a break but I don't I
don't feel the I don't see the need for
all them outfits I just feel like it be
so frantic it is it's like I don't see
the need um what's your favorite song on
the EP on my EP
um I really like the first song fading
away and I really like the song with me
and Monica shout out to Monica shout out
to her she's a legend gona was it you
guys uh obviously she's someone who you
grew up listening to yes and definitely
a big deal to do full circle moment yeah
like I a never think I'd be doing no
song with Monica like yeah like when I
was a kid it was like Monica and Brandy
that's like when I thought I like R&B
like chicks it was Monica and Brandy mhm
yeah it was them too and then and it's
super dope cuz I get to grow up and be a
part of it and they're still like around
yeah have you ever uh like H how how
long do you want to do
music that's a good question um I want
to do music because you know like
sometimes you'll see people like like
you know uh bry's a perfect example like
we haven't had Brandy like brandy will
like come and go like every five or six
seven years like she kind of does it as
she pleases now that she's kind of like
a OG is it something like you want to
okay so I want to have like so I I
dropped my very first EP when I first
came here it did really well multiple
platinum records congrats double
Platinum thank you um and then like that
was 2018 and then in 2022 years later I
dropped my debut album misunderstood MH
um which just went gold congratulations
that's a big deal especially nowadays
yeah and so three years later I was
supposed to be dropping my my sophomore
album um but instead I dropped the EP
because like paperwork that be taking
too long like yeah you well you know
what it is these labels they're like
well if it's going to count as an album
yeah yeah so I the the the way I do it
the way I I on my contract I have to
have 12 songs on an album if I already
dropped four songs and then I turn
around and drop a eight song EP my
contract is done I mean not my contract
but that portion of the contract so that
they'll consider that a 12 song oh
that's smart cuz sometimes you you'll
see these major labels they they'll be
like no this is a mixtape so it doesn't
count against your deal it counts for me
my next my next next uh album is going
to consider my third third third album
again yeah yeah and I have four so I
would have one more left with who I'm
signed to but um Capital right yeah
Capital Records um dang what was I going
to say what you ask me to do this music
[__] what I was going to say is I if I
could just get a super duper successful
like album um well you already got a
gold one well yeah I know but like I
don't know like I just feel like it's
something more that I'm trying to I
don't know what it is it's something
more that I want but I don't know what
it is um I think once I get more of a
the a
general uh of the general public fan
base um then I will I'm also working on
releasing like launching a product too
um a like a line I don't know if it's I
don't know if I want to call it a
clothing line but just something really
comfy um if I'm really if I have a
really successful business with that
then I could take a break because I
don't have to depend on making music for
money just do it cuz you want to